they're trying to keep things moving but
it's not always possible
this bus company in the east midlands
has lost 10 percent of its drivers and
across the country there's a shortage of
more than 4 000 bus drivers
many tempted away by big salaries on
offer to drive hdvs instead
the mindset of the
bus drivers at the moment is that over
in the haulage industry the employers
threw money at the problem at the
shortage so the mindset is now we might
as well do it for 20 pounds an hour
driving a lorry as 10 pounds an hour
driving a bus
a shortage of drivers means fewer buses
can run the cancellation's a problem for
those with no other way to get around i
need two buses still and i'm trying to
get to work yeah
it's quite inconvenient if my next bus
gets knocked off the service because i
go up and work at
a warehouse but i feel for the older
people who can't walk into town you
can't get
to the hospital if you haven't got
transport it's having an impact on a
daily basis at the moment the bus
companies know their customers aren't
happy
we can't compete with the logistics and
distribution sector at this moment in
time couldn't you just pay drivers more
it's difficult to do more than we have
because other cost pressures are also
going up so fuel for example is costing
us 100 000 pounds more so far in 2021
than it did in 2020 because the price of
fuel is escalated
the department for transport say they're
working closely with the bus sector over
workforce issues
all passengers can do is wait worry and
wonder if they'll get where they need to
go becky johnson sky news derbyshire